- You know, we were 20
when the internet was even
starting to start to start.
And it was definitely not like
the same as like it is today
and now it's completely
flipped upside down.
So John 15 year old, John right now
only dreams of going viral
or winning on the internet
and 48 year old John still subconsciously
'cause of the way he grew up,
thinks of it as a step down.
I understand both.
- [Man] You got your perspective.
I just wanna be happy,
don't you want to be happy?
- This is exciting for me.
- Those are remade Megos,
those aren't original Megos.
- That's what I love.
Yes, they are, they're called Figures
from Figures Toy Company.
I looked for my old...
you're the perfect person for this
by the way we started the podcast.
- I love it.
- Cause everything that
I've been learning about you
with going to like garage sales, I guess
and eBay and all that kind of stuff.
I was looking for a podcast set.
And I was trying to think, what is me?
What talks about me?
What tells about, and in my childhood
which is where I wish I still was.
So I went looking for my Mego toys.
Oh, I must've sold them at a garage sale
to some guy who became
famous on the internet.
(laughs)
But I couldn't find 'em.
And you know there were some
on eBay and stuff like that.
I did get some
but there were Figures toys
and I just looked it up
and their remakes of the Megos, the,
I think they're five and a half inch
I also had the little ones too
the Mego minis or whatever they're called.
But they were, you know
they were really dolls,
they weren't action figures.
- Correct.
- And they were awesome
as a kid growing up
and everything's changed so much
Todd McFarlane on
and you talk about going
the exact opposite way.
The detail in those was incredible.
These were like, they take the same head
and just paint it differently.
- A hundred percent.
They were barbies and let's
call them what they were.
(laughing)
- Yes and when I was growing up
my dad would have been mad at that
and nowadays it would be perfect.
- Correct.
- It would be 100% way to go.
So you are the guest today, Gary V
and I didn't know much about you.
I'm honest on this podcast a lot of times
I used to try and be something I wasn't.
I used to try and be a really good host.
- Yep.
- You're one of the people I actually
I've heard talk about this, you know
talk about being yourself
and that comes through
and I get lost, you know,
I'm all over the place.
That's why I do the impressions.
- Same.
- Really?
- Oh, yeah.
I can be focused when I'm
like building a business,
but like, I'm the worst. I also
on my podcast, I'm terrible
I cut off the person's 740...
My fans like want to punch me in the face
when I'm like doing, yeah
I'm quite creative in a lot of ways
that I didn't realize as a kid
'cause all the creative
energy went into business
and that didn't seem creative back then.
But your earlier point
of your dad and adult
like the word entrepreneur
didn't even exist.
I was gonna be a businessman.
And that seemed like money
and money didn't seem like creative
or art or things of that nature.
But like, yeah.
I mean, I have like
six thoughts right now.
I'm like thinking about
your Ghostbuster figures.
I was pumped to see Plastic
Man in the background.
Like I'm like thinking
about the Hogan figure.
I'm thinking about some of your
impressions that I've loved.
Like was I mad 'cause I saw
that in before Jets game,
that was bad.
Like, it's amazing how many places
in 13 seconds your brain can actually go.
- Yeah. And see
well, I would not have
thought that at all.
See, I would've thought
you were extremely focused.
You know, what got me--
- I call it controlled chaos.
I can be micro focused
but I'm macro most happy in chaos.
- Could you stop interrupting me?
I wouldn't have thought that 'cause
so I go back to when I
started, I got off the internet
so my story is this.
When I was starting to make a little bit
of a name for myself
back in Fox, NFL Sunday
and doing stuff on TBS and
even a little bit "Mad TV"
the internet was just starting
to blow up a little bit.
When I first got to Hollywood
people didn't even really have email.
The email was just starting
and people like I had a manager's like
you're not gonna believe this
you can type a message to
somebody on the keyboard
and you send it across the country
and they get it in seconds.
So that world, I was at one point
the number one thing on YouTube
before there were any
subscribers or anything like that
just YouTube
there was even a thing where people
like the Frank Caliendo factor of YouTube
where people you know
small blogs would talk
about that type of thing.
But I got lost in it.
I didn't see it.
Like when Microsoft
didn't see what Apple saw
I didn't see the future of that.
- Which is very common Frank.
I remember you on YouTube
I was there very early
with Wine Library TV
in February 2006, when it was
like Rocketboom and Ze Frank
and all this stuff I
know because Hollywood
you thought of yourself that way,
these things were a micro
little stepping stone
to the big game.
YouTube was like a small club
you would play on your way.
I remember it vividly that the 2002, three
four, five, six, seven era
really and then it started to
change, but like, '01 to '06
to your point, it was like a place
you were using to get somewhere
and what I definitely understood
back then was like, no, no
this is gonna be the somewhere.
- Yeah 'cause I was actually
getting mad about it.
I had more people recognizing
me from YouTube at the time
than I did when after doing Letterman.
And that annoyed me
and that's the wrong way to look at it.
That's what I've learned is, you know
perspective is everything.
That's something you talk about
Ed Mylett was another
guy who's gotten me into
I saw some of your, I saw
all of your interview with Ed
but Ed was when I was starting to get back
into the internet, I got away from it
just because I was on Twitter
and I was building an audience
on Twitter and it was so angry.
I describe it as like New
York city being in Manhattan
and when you're walking in Times Square
and everybody's bumping into each other
and nobody cares and they just
start swearing at each other
and they don't care.
I just couldn't hack it.
I mean, it was one of those
things I'm just sitting there
so I just got away.
But I met Ed and started getting into it.
I learned about you and some
of the other influencers
I don't know if you even like that term.
- You know at this point
you get, so, you know
to your point, it's funny, like
when you put yourself
out there and I'm sure
this happens for you
and really at this point
'cause everybody puts
themselves out there.
Everybody's getting
labeled as something like
I'm just grateful that I
have the chance to be labeled
you know, whatever that label is.
So keep going.
- Well, what I was thinking about is
well I wanna go with your labeling thing
it doesn't annoy you at all?
I mean, to me--
- It's kind of like
your gift is your curse.
I, you know, have built
businesses my whole life
and built a huge business for my dad
in the wine and liquor business, you know
in the last 24 months had a
restaurant app called Resy
that I started co-founded
with Ben Leventhal
sell for hefty nine figures to Amex.
I sold my direct to consumer
wine brand Empathy Wines
for almost a hundred million dollars.
VaynerMedia is a $200 million a year,
almost $200 million a year
revenue based business
that I've started from scratch
yet when I get mentioned on the internet
and you read the
comments, everyone's like,
well he's just fucking
a motivational speaker.
And so, you know, as any human,
when you work your face off
and you accomplish, you know,
it's funny to answer you
'cause even as I'm saying
it, ultimately I don't mind
'cause I understand how
human beings are wired
thus is why I've done well.
But yeah, I mean, I, you know
I think we all get miffed
you know, I don't wanna be
you know, I love perspective and mindset
'cause I think it's foundational
to helping people go do things.
But I think there's a lot
of characters that, you know
just speak for the sake of speaking
and don't have the resume or
the execution underneath them.
And of course, there's times
that I wish that was recognized more
but you know, I also know that
when you have drillions of videos
of you speaking on stage being consumed,
that's the only context and
so I have to be empathetic
because I'm the one creating those videos
and distributing them.
- Well, you know, I can
relate to that a lot
because when I used to get
mad at people seeing me
as just the impressionist guy
but then I realized that's
all I'm putting out there.
I'm putting that out there constantly.
- Not only putting it out
there, the platform you had
I mean that's definitely the first time
I became aware of it.
Like when so many of the
percentage of people see that
because the platform was so big
that you were being
consumed on to your point
this is about empathy to the
end-user of understanding
well, that's what they see.
- So do you think,
I know a little bit about
your story that you built
your parents' wine business
was worth like $3 million.
- It was doing $3 million a year.
And I grew it to a business that was doing
$65 million a year in a eight year period.
- And that's by bringing
it to the internet
and realizing you didn't
need to have 8,000 stores
you could just have--
- Your story about YouTube,
Hollywood was my story
about email versus catalogs.
I understood in 1997 that the
biggest stores in the country
Sam's in Chicago, Sherri-Lehmans
and Zachys in New York
Wine Club and Wine Exchange and K&L Wines.
These stores that I looked up to
because I'd been in the
business since I was 14
and the Wednesday, New
York Times dining edition
would have all the national ads.
And I was like, one day
I'm gonna help my dad
and I'm gonna take us
to the national level
like these stores
and those stores that I just
rattled off or those stores
I realized in 1997 that I could email out
Opus One or Dom Perignon
or Silver Oak or Caymus
or these great wines on email for free
back to the agent joke you made earlier
while my competitors these iconic stores
were taking three months
producing a catalog
that cost them a crap load of money
and cost a lot of money to
deliver and would be two months
two weeks, six weeks, six days
later than I could email it
and I really, really
took advantage of that.
And I understood that this was crazy
this isn't what people thought in 1996.
I understood that rich people
that bought expensive wine would use email
and reply and say they want six bottles
and literally (indistinct)
crazy for every listener
people debated me saying
that the affluent individuals
wouldn't like that experience
they would rather order it from a catalog.
People always do that, they do it now.
Instagram influencers didn't go on Tik Tok
because they were insecure and
didn't wanna start all over
so they would make up excuses that Tik Tok
was only for girls dancing
when it was obvious
what was happening there
people don't like change
and I love change.
And that has been a huge
foundation of my career.
- You're kind of describing
me with even Tik Tok there.
I didn't wanna get on it at the beginning.
Tik Tok was recruiting me to get on there.
Now this is when it had just
switched over from Musically
and I looked at it and I would open it up
and I felt like I was going to go to jail
every time something played
and it's changed, it's changed.
Especially, I guess the
Vine people found it.
People like you found it
but what happened was that it evolved.
And even now, when I tell
people about Tik Tok,
I'm like it's not the same.
It's not just sounds and stuff like that
and you know, lip syncing
it's a lot of content.
- Frank that's the thing
that I'm good at as well
and I think other people
that have the investing
or business career that
I have are also good at.
They're able to look
at MTV in 1984 and say,
okay this is not free music.
I don't know if you know this story.
Most of the big bands in
the late '70s early '80s
refused to make music videos
because they thought it
was giving away free music.
And Sticks for example
'cause I remember speaking
to the Sticks manager
literally decided not to make videos
because that was giving away
music for free fuck you.
You meanwhile, Duran Duran
and van Halen and you know
and Twisted Sister were thrilled to do it
and then became the biggest
bands in the world in that era.
I've always valued the
attention of society
over the short term economics
of the transaction of a sale.
So I would rather go to
the new place, work hard,
figure out how to bring value
through my content there
and be there when it became
the thing versus somebody
I like how you just reacted,
where do you mind just go?
- I'm laughing because
you're exactly the opposite
of everything I've ever thought
that I've realized I was
wrong about recently.
When people would ask me,
"Hey, are you gonna go
up to the comedy store.
You're gonna go up to the
Laugh Factory and do a set?"
When I lived in LA, I live in Arizona now.
I just thought it'd be a
better place to raise a family
and stuff outside of Hollywood.
So, which is part of my
issue, I made a choice.
I've heard you talk about, you know
time management and stuff with that family
I made a conscious choice
my guilt with family and stuff
guilt seems like a negative connotation,
but it's what I cared about.
I'm glad that I'm here for my kids--
- 'Cause it's a mix of
gratitude and guilt.
- Yeah.
And it's trying to find that balance.
I went way over to the family side
'cause I just knew that was me.
I just needed to be--
- No, no, let's stay here
'cause I think it's gonna
help a lot of people
you know, we're getting to know each other
I love you for that.
'Cause you clearly, it's
funny you talk professionally
about the chess moves but I
actually think in your real life
clearly what you care about the most
you actually foresaw the game
which is one day my kids are gonna be 20
I'm never going to get this back.
I can feel it.
I literally have goosebumps
I don't know if you can see
them through the screen.
I was like, this guy's interesting.
He realized it in the real
life but professionally
because it was so pushed on him
that make people pay for your value
like people in Hollywood
and in Wall Street
and in Madison Avenue, they overvalue
like restriction and they
undervalue awareness.
- Yeah. I mean I've always
been super aware of everything
like comedy--
- I'm sorry I bet awareness
from like every rep matters
because if one more
person knows who you are
that's going to matter long-term
and a lot of the
monetization of restrictions
my favorite one Hollywood's
obsessed with overexposure.
There's no overexposure.
- Well there used to be, but
there's a new perspective
on stuff there isn't--
- There used to be ish.
What happened was music was hard
and like playing The Fonz was hard.
Like overexposure was very unique.
It was people would get caught
with such an iconic role
that we couldn't stop
seeing them in that role
from an acting standpoint,
the Fonz, you know
whoever we can do a million of these
you know, Oracle, like,
you know, Tony Soprano,
and then artists would get a lot of plays
to your point, there was only MTV
I mean, if you're Madonna
and you were promoting a new album
you could actually get all
of America to know it was out
if you did 13 things, that
world doesn't exist anymore.
- Right. Well, and I think
people have been desensitized.
If you open up Tik Tok you
might see the guy playing
the straw hammer whatever that is
five times in the next 10 minutes
that person seems overexposed,
I guess not even overexposed
that person seems like you see
them just as much as you see
let's say Michael Strahan
who's doing six jobs on television.
So we don't even see it anymore.
We don't understand it
because it's changed
so much in front of us.
- What you're actually describing
is a different point in my opinion
which is the attention of the
world is in a different place.
And so if you're in the
business world of entertainment
you know that Michael
Strahan does six shows
and he's unbelievably successful
in classic Hollywood
in entertainment terms.
But if you're living
in the practical world
you're realizing that
attention is staggeringly
quickly shifting to 15
platforms on the internet
and whoever is winning there is winning.
- Yeah.
I still lump it all together.
What you are able to
do is compartmentalize
and see these different pieces of media.
And that's just me trying to go
from old school to this
new school way of thinking.
I mean, Pat McAfee, do you
know Pat McAfee's huge podcast?
He's the guy who actually got
me back into the internet.
He started me going he's like
you should be killing on there
doing voiceovers, doing this, doing that.
I was like ah
and I didn't want to--
- Keep going.
- Well I just
I'll tell you this keep
going, you're good at that.
I just didn't want to
'cause I saw myself and my podcast partner
who's not here right now.
This is the way he still thinks
and we fight about this all the time
fight in terms of he's the
number one radio guy in Phoenix.
He's a seven figure guy.
He's set and he's really
happy, which is perfect.
And I've heard you talk about that too.
When you're happy with where
you're at, that's great.
- Five figures, six figures, seven figures
when you're happy game over.
- And probably the most
talented guy I've ever met
with impressions, the ability,
he's kinda like a
combination of, you know,
the shock jock DJ who can
also do the sidekick stuff
in terms of impressions,
characters, he's got it all.
I mean he and I go back and forth
we work on impressions together
it's a great teamwork in dichotomy.
We get along really well
he's like a slightly
more evil version of me
which is, in this world good
and bad but he's edgier.
And he takes a lot more risks.
I find myself working in
corporate America a lot
so I don't take as many chances
I back off quite a bit.
But he doesn't like the internet at all.
And I got back on the internet
and started getting on there
and I said, I have to
find this new audience.
- What does he not like about it Frank?
I apologize, I'm just curious.
- You know, it just feels
like a step down to him.
Although he--
- Did he grow up wanting
to be an entertainer?
- I think he grew up wanting to do radio.
He wanted it to be a writer too.
- Yeah. I mean, that's
listen it's the song as old as time
like every 15 year old
in America right now
13 year old wants to be an
influencer when they grow up.
That was no different.
- You know what I'd say
that except for my kid.
- Fair enough.
Of course, it's, you know--
- My son's going to listen to this.
I'm a year older than you.
So born in '74 so how old are you?
- I'm gonna turn 45 in
a couple of weeks here.
- So I'm 46, I'll be 47 in January.
- So a couple things.
- When you and I were
growing up, you know,
being an actor or you
know, on TV was, you know
and I didn't want to be because
I wanted to be a businessman
but like half the class
did or in a different way
almost all of us would have taken it.
Do you know what I mean?
I think some people were, you know
and I think to your point, I mean
the ideology of your
partner was in that era
is he in our age group in general range?
- Yeah. He's two years
older than me, I think.
- Perfect.
So John, like, you know, we were 20
when the internet was even
starting to start to start
and it was definitely like
the same as like it is today
and now it's completely
flipped upside down.
So John 15 year old John right now
only dreams of going viral
or winning on the internet
and 48 year old John still subconsciously
'cause of the way he grew up,
thinks of it as a step down.
I understand both.
- Yeah I've felt like that
a lot until I realized,
hey I gotta get in front of
a lot of different people.
I struggle with this too
;cause this is another thing
I've heard you talk about.
I feel like I'm in a
therapy session with you.
- It's good.
- It's been a learning experience
and it's been a difficult step for me
to put some stuff out.
It's hard on Tik Tok these
kids don't know me at all
it's funny 'cause these
kids will tell me things
like oh, that impression sucks.
I'm like, well it built
this 70,000 gallon pool.
(laughs)
It's good enough.
- By the way Frank,
I'll be honest with you
just play with me here a little bit.
This could be interesting.
I think that should be something you try.
I think the--
- I've thought about it.
- Well let me tell you something
this is very, very big.
This is the punchline of this podcast
and we're gonna help three
people who are listening
right now I can feel into my soul.
The biggest difference
between what made you great
and you became you and this exact second
is the, I thought about
it is the vulnerability.
You know you grew up in a world.
I get it.
- You're gonna make me cry.
- 'Cause it's good right?
You see I'm excited about this because
the I thought about it once
by the way, Kevin James
let's talk about Kevin James.
Kevin James' team calls
me a year ago, whatever
15 months ago we get on
the call and we have this
I remember I'm in
California on the highway
in between meetings, just on a call.
And we have this like really interesting.
I just had like a 30 minute
like jam session with them.
'Cause you know, Kevin's a Jets fan.
You know, we'd interacted a little bit
and there was just something
I don't remember what
but something landed
in the same way that I'm
trying to land with you
don't think about it.
And I just remember the whole team
the writing team and him on there
and it clicked and so
much good has happened
on Tik TOK and other things for him since.
And I genuinely believe the
same thing would happen for you
which is in a world
where you perfected shit
before you showed the world
what's so fun about this is you
get to perfect it with them,
not without them.
And when I tell you that if
you started a whole shtick
of you razzing the kids razzing you
like in the meta of it,
that would fucking crush.
- Well this is gonna
become a Tik Tok itself
with you saying that
that'll justify the
reason for me doing it.
That's what I needed was...
Listen I'd thought about that.
I thought about taking
the replies, the, you know
the reply videos, the
comments, the negative comments
I'd even mapped one out in my head
here are the following
impressions people say on Tik Tok
that I do that they say suck.
- I think that you should 100% do that
be when you make a video
saying, hey Ricky Pants 67
and then show him saying this sucks
be like, you think that sucks?
What about letting you know?
Like whatever you go with it,
whatever the transition is.
- Okay. So you're jumping
into a world of, okay.
See, I love the idea
of, hey, I'll show you
but at the same time--
- Yeah I love you already.
- I struggle with, I
don't wanna put it, but it
you know where I'm going that
because then I look like the big bad wolf.
- King douche.
No no you play with it for fun.
You'll appreciate this and
I'm getting a sense of you.
You know, what has absolutely
worked for me and others?
Intent.
- Right.
- People are like Gary V like, you know
- And that would be
the tone of it as well.
The tone, the way you put it up.
- Or you invite the kid to swim.
Like there's a million
places you can do it.
(laughs)
- Invite the kid to swim during COVID.
I got these other four kids
they're coughing it'll be fun.
(laughs)
Okay, here's my Iron Man jackass.
- But Frank it really is intent.
I remember when I first started
putting out content 2009
and I didn't know this
and this goes into your
world a little bit.
I didn't realize how much Richard Pryor
and I listen to so much
Richard Pryor and Eddie Murphy
and Chris Rock as a kid, like when I drove
it was sports radio or tape of standup.
And so I'm 34 years old when
I gave my first keynote speech
about business.
And when I tell you I had no fucking idea
what was gonna happen when I
went on stage, I had no idea.
I just went on there.
And what happened was
when the lights went on
for some reason, I decided
that I was gonna communicate
as if I was doing a set in a very improv.
And it was really funny
to me that that happened.
And I think what, so I
was cursing like crazy.
And I was getting so much pushback.
It was, you know, 12 years
ago, it was a different time
and I remember people
begging me to change my style
CAA who did my speaking
'cause I hit very quickly and became hot
and CA was doing my speaking at the time
and they begged me big
shout out to Peter Jacobs.
They begged me to stop cursing.
They were like, you know,
you will make so much
it's back to your point
earlier about corporate America
and the way you think about
what you're gonna do and not do.
- Before you go on already
I know Peter Jacobs, that's the high end.
Keep going.
- Yeah. So exactly.
So I just couldn't do it.
I just needed to do me
and was willing to deal
with the ramifications.
And then the world came to
me and the reason it happened
was I had intent.
It's how I actually spoke.
It's how I naturally felt.
And I had good intent.
I wasn't trying to hurt people
I was trying to use it
to get them to hear it.
And I think if you come out with intent
of not being a big show
but just having fun
with the community and enjoying yourself--
- Yeah. I mean, it makes sense.
It makes sense because you
can do that in a jovial way.
That's what I'm trying
to do with the podcast.
to do with everything.
Listen, I'm trying to get
people to understand who I am
'cause I'm much more
sarcastic in real life.
I'm goofy and stuff like that.
But people see me as the walks, the line
maybe it goes even halfway to
the line, but on the podcast
I go all the way to the line,
sometimes go over the line.
It's me, you know, we say
things behind the scenes
well you don't, you talk exactly
maybe I shouldn't say it,
I don't know you that well
but you go out there and
what you're showing is you
you're burring your soul
when you go out there.
Listen, these impressions that I do
it's a mask for me to hide, right?
It's a way for me, I'm a kid who grew up
watching all these TV shows
of all the stuff you saw behind me.
I was by myself playing with my Legos.
My parents were like you ever
gonna come out of your room?
No, I have my friends.
They're super friends.
They're going (indistinct)
You know, that's who I was
and hiding is what I've always been.
And this, this internet stuff,
when I go out there and look
you know, you see people, the best people
are the people who put it all out there
and you see the emotion.
I learned this--
- Can I judge real quick?
The ones that have the
sustained success are the ones,
because there's a lot
of people, to your point
who are absolutely putting up facades
without acknowledging it.
The beauty of impressions
is I know let me rephrase,
I don't think most people
enjoy psychology enough
to know that that's what you were doing
but I do, whereas a lot of people
are saying they're being
authentic but then not.
And they're the ones that
can't have sustained success
to your point, the sustained success
you know how fun it is
to not have to think?
Frank I never have to think
everything I talk, I talk,
like, there's no like,
like when I go to the
restaurant, like I better be like
when you could just be yourself 24/7.
- I'd love to get there man.
I'm getting better at it.
But Dennis Miller started
screaming at me on a podcast.
He's like, Frankie just
be you (indistinct)
what are you doing?
He's just screaming at
me to just be myself
and people don't understand
I've built these walls around me.
This was the thing I noticed
I learned on Tik Tok.
I do the impressions.
I haven't even gotten to the part
of really showing the me stuff
and even on Tik Tok and
what I do differently there
and the reason I keep referencing Tik Tok
I find it the fastest place to grow.
- You're growing like crazy
and you're being more creative.
- Yes. There's a level of creativity
and what gets me to do it the motivation
is the ability to grow quickly.
I mean, it's--
- You know what?
I love you for that sentence.
Like, that's a big deal
to acknowledge that
because I'll be honest with
you I love that as a entree
but you have to basically
spend all your time
getting out of that mindset
'cause it's similar to being
in the room with the Legos.
The judgment of others and
calibrating it is everything.
- Yeah.
- The reason real
celebrities hate social media
is they don't want the
insecurity of low numbers
and Tik Tok--
- Right, absolutely.
You see something going down
and I have a group of friends
you know, people will
just text me all the time.
What is the algorithm doing?
And I'm like, I don't know.
I've started to just give up on that
I used to hide the low number ones.
And then I looked around at some of
I realized a lot of people are doing that.
A lot of people are deleting, hiding,
you know screw it, whatever.
- Nobody gives a shit at the end.
- Yeah.
- In the end, nobody gives a shit.
- Yeah. I mean, I don't know.
For me it's hard to, 'cause there are
it's trying to go from an old mindset
of what we used to look at.
- Here's my thing.
My biggest thing is you
have so much creative talent
I'm devastated that you
overthinking something may stop you
from making your signature piece of work.
- Well That's where I'm
getting to that point
is I'm getting to a point where I've said
I'm just gonna start throwing
a lot more stuff out there
I've heard you talking about it.
- And by the way it's not spray and pray
and throw against the
wall and see what sticks.
These are actual thoughts in your mind
and you're gonna put them out.
That's a big difference.
A lot of people are like,
oh it's garbage Gary.
You've talked about volume and quantity
but that's at the expense of quality.
I'm like, who gets to judge quality?
- Commentors.
- But that's why it needs to go out.
Listen I just think it's an
incredible time to be creative.
And I'm pumped that you're
putting the pieces together
to get there in a world where
you've got 40 plus years
to give.
- Well you don't know me that we'll see--
- I don't but when I say that
I really genuinely believe it.
And you're in a craft, unlike
athletes, when I say that
you know and we're of the
same age, Milton Berle, right?
you start going into these names, right
where you know, George Burns, you know
Bob Hope like these were old
fuckers when we were kids
but they were still doing their thing.
- Right, yeah.
By the way, are you on a time?
- Yeah I should've left three minutes ago
but I'm enjoying myself
and I'm literally texting
my business client to wait a few seconds.
- Okay. Then I'll get to the wrap up here.
Listen, to me I found that emotion
and not even always trying to be funny
people find emotion on the internet
especially on Tik Tok and
they gravitate toward that.
I did those Robin Williams
thing that I was just like
you know, I miss them, oh
my God, where is, you know
that kind of thing and
people went crazy for that.
And it's just a learning experience.
It's trying to find out
even what people, you know
for taking myself out of
the internet for awhile
and then getting back just
to see what actually worked
and what it was.
- Frank, think of it this way.
I'm gonna give you a
prescription on my way out.
And I think it's gonna work
for you, I really mean it.
Make one for them
because that's what you're
talking about right now
make one for them and then
just make one for yourself
every time, two pills a day,
one for them, one for you
'cause I promise you brother
on my fucking heart and soul
the one that you make for yourself
is gonna be the one
that changes everything.
You see where I'm going right?
My biggest fear is that
so many of the people
that fit your profile are sitting on gold
and will talk themselves
out of it for no reason.
- I'm a big talker
in terms of talking
myself out of everything.
- It's why I'm leaning into this one.
I think what's so amazing
about Tik Tok for you
right this second, because it will change
(indistinct) will go away
just like every platform
I've been doing this for 20 years Frank,
the growing like crazy will just stop
'cause ads are gonna come in
it happens on every platform.
- I've already seen it start.
- You have 18 months.
And in that 18 months,
I believe that you make
up a fake character
because we have this talk and
you just decide to do that.
And that character becomes
your billion dollar
movie franchise.
- It's the same things, it's
just great to hear from you.
- You were about to say I'm
having those same thoughts
and I'm just desperately trying
to suffocate it right now
from thoughts to action.
- To just make it happen.
Two things before you get going,
one do you know how this
interview came about?
And I'm so glad it did
because I've learned a lot
and I'm gonna utilize it.
- I know that it was somebody
close to me talking about you.
Like, I it's been on my mind.
- Sean O'Neil who was a multiple
US table tennis champion
who's taught me a lot about
ping pong, table tennis.
He texted me he goes do you
want Gary V on your show?
I'm like, he's not gonna do the show.
It's a small little podcast.
It's just fun.
I don't know if you know
him personally or what
but he did that and
then it worked out nice.
Since then, I've watched
a lot more of your stuff
and how you reach out to charities
and that's how I'm thinking
of myself right here.
And he had one question
that I wanted to ask you for him quickly
which was in terms of sports,
- Yes.
- What do you think kids should do?
And this is kind of a reach,
but you think they should focus
on one sport or multiple sports?
- Multiple sports.
- Because you never know.
- Because I think they should focus
on multiple sports early on.
And then if they think
they're gonna be professionals
they can zone in.
But I think the specialization
at the young age right now
is more predicated on delusional parents
that think their kids are
going to the (indistinct).
I think a lot of times by
limiting children early on
you're taking away some skill sets
that they might be able to take.
I actually think some parents
are gonna stop their kids
from going to the (indistinct)
by making them one
dimensional too early, AKA
"You're gonna be a baseball player son"
and what they could have
learned in basketball or soccer
or change them up a little
bit from a skill set
I actually think it's
a huge mistake because
when I tell you the number
one delusional animal
in the world is parents about
their kids going into sports
it's unbelievable to me how
many people are confused.
- Yeah.
And kids' sports are, I don't
know if it's just COVID.
- Big business.
- But it's going way down.
Have you seen recently?
The numbers are going way down.
People are gonna lose teamwork.
Okay. I know you gotta go.
The last thing is this
with your business acumen
and prowess, how can you wear a Jets hat?
I just don't understand,
have they ever come
to you and said, can you
talk to us and help us?
- The Jets were one of my early clients
but the only way I'm
gonna be able to help them
is to accomplish my lifelong dream
of buying them and then
managing it myself.
I can wear it because I love the process.
I am loyal.
It's my squad.
I'm not gonna bail
just 'cause we're the
worst team in the NFL
and that's who I am.
- All right.
I was looking for a joke answer
but I'm glad I got the honesty.
- You got the one.
Frank real pleasure, man.
Continued success.
- All right thanks man.
- YouTube watcher, what's up. It's Gary V
first of all, thank you so much.
I hope you're doing super
well during these times.
I also wanna ask you please subscribe
because my commitment and
exploration of YouTube
is about to explode stories, polls
more content, more engagement,
more surprise and delight.
This is the time to subscribe.
I hope you consider it.
And I hope I see you soon.